GOING TO HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW AND
TOMORROW MORNING.
>> Sean: STAY SAFE.
THE HOLLYWOOD HATE MACHINE IS
UNHINGED AS EVER.
WALMART SHOPPERS, LIKE ME.
I LOVE WALMART.
I THINK COSTCO, WALMART, THEY
ARE THE BEST STORES EVER.
LOOK AT DEBRA MESSING, ACTRESS
ALONG WITH HER WILL AND GRACE
COSTAR.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THE SHOW.
SHE ACTUALLY WANTS TO SPREAD A
LIST AT AN UPCOMING FUND-RAISER,
APPARENTLY AS SOME SORT OF
INTIMIDATION TACTIC.
IT'S GETTING PRETTY SICK, PRETTY
TO DOMINIC TWISTED, PRETTY DARK.
WHOOPI GOLDBERG EARLIER SAID
TODAY THAT THIS IS NUTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, SHE DID NOT STOP
THERE.
SAYING "THE PRESIDENT IS
MENTALLY ILL."
WE HAVE THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS UNDER
DONALD TRUMP THAN WE'VE EVER HAD
AND HISPANIC-AMERICANS AND
RECORD NUMBERS OF WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
EVEN A CATEGORY 5 HURRICANE
DOESN'T SLOW DOWN THE ENDLESS
SMEARS.
HBO PRODUCER, DAVID SIMON
ACTUALLY TWEETED CALLING AND
BEGGING GOD TO DESTROY MERRILL
LONGA      .
RADICALS, RESISTANCE, THE LAUGHS
PLANS TO REBUILD AMERICA.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
MIKE HUCKABEE.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK, JUDGE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO RESPOND
TO THIS, BECAUSE YOU CANNOT TALK
THESE PEOPLE OUT OF THE HATE,
RAGE, AND PSYCHOSIS.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS WHAT I TALK
ABOUT IN MY BOOK.
THIS IS ANOTHER PERSON IN
HOLLYWOOD WHO IS OUT TO DOMINIC
FOR REVENGE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WHO IS
THIS WOMAN WHO TAKES THE WORDS
THAT OTHER PEOPLE GIVE HER TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE IN
HOLLYWOOD SHOULD WORK OR NOT
WORK.
THIS IS McCARTHYISM.
THIS IS AS DARK AS IT GETS.
TO SAY THAT YOU SHOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO EXPRESS YOUR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS, YOU SHOULDN'T
VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP JUST
BECAUSE YOU ARE A TRUMP
SUPPORTER, YOU ARE A RACIST.
>> Sean: NO.
WE ARE SMELLY WALMART SHOPPERS.
WE CLING TO OUR BIBLES AND
RELIGION.
GUILTY.
GOVERNOR, YOU'RE MORE GUILTY
THAN ME.
>> I TRY TO BE.
I REALLY DO.
I WANT TO BE THE MOST GUILTY GUY
IN AMERICA TO BELIEVE IN THE
THINGS THAT REALLY MATTER.
YOU KNOW, I CALL IT GOD, GUNS,
GOODS, AND GRAVY.
THAT MEANS THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE EMBRACE
CULTURALLY, BUT THANK GOD FOR
WHOOPI GOLDBERG, WHO RECOGNIZED
THAT WHAT DEBORAH MESSING IS
ASKING FOR IS TOO FAR.
WHEN YOU START GOING DOWN THE
LIST AND SAYING THAT THESE
PEOPLE SUPPORT A POLITICAL
CANDIDATE I DON'T LIKE, WE ARE
GOING TO PUT YOU OUT OF
BUSINESS, THAT IS McCARTHYISM.
I'VE GOT A LIST.
>> Sean: SHE BAKES THEM FOR
THE MEDIA AND THEY STILL DIDN'T
BELIEVE SHE BAKED THEM.
>> MY DAUGHTER IS A LOT NICER
THAN ME.
I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE TAKEN THE
PIE AND SHOVED IT IN THE FACE OF
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE.
SHE SIMPLY SERVED ONE AND SAID,
HEY, TRY IT OUT AND SEE.
BUT SHE IS A MUCH NICER PERSON
THAN HER FATHER.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THIS REMINDS ME
OF?
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE SAYING TO
PEOPLE, WE DON'T WANT YOU TO
WORK IF YOU SUPPORT
DONALD TRUMP.
WE WANT YOU TO LOSE YOUR JOB.
THESE PEOPLE ARE OUT RIGHT
HATERS AND THEY WANT TO REMAKE
AMERICA.
>> Sean: IT'S LIKE
HUMPTY DUMPTY.